[Music]
ELF bowling PG Oh
oh yeah know how that one is PG that
makes sense in fact how is that not more
than PG but how's the anime movie based
on the game PG
[Music]
else bowling is based on a computer game
from the late 90s about Santa throwing a
bowling ball at striking elves thank you
baby I guess not really anything that
special so of course it became a big hit
it was spread all throughout the
internet and even got picked up by other
game councils where it was proudly
labeled as one of the most enchanting ly
worst games of all time now the
developers must have gotten the idea to
do movies because in 2007 ELF bowling
the movie was released to a very similar
response that's the tagline ask can
Christmas be spared
not with your greedy ass is making these
films it's okay though at the back of
the box reads this beautiful computer
graphics movie is perfect for the whole
family parental guidance suggested what
are the guide in the month
what elf asses actually look like
there's a lot to get bowled over by so
let's jump right in let's take a look at
our last Christmas movie of the year
this is elf boy from America to Britain
[Music]
okay two points for not starting off in
any way how I thought this film would
start off
Who am I kidding if this was a Disney
film at the Alice and the curse of the
black hole this ship is called the
filthy toe and they hold the evilest of
pirates known to man the ones who steal
toys and sell them for profit
[Music]
so that's what happened to the SS Toys R
Us put all them treats of stolen toys in
me cabin and make it snappy you're
burning out what's what the bazaar
captain's what'd you say make it snappy
yup burning out lots okay I don't know
what the rest of the film is gonna give
me but I thank you for adding barnacle
butts to my dictionary of obscurely
confusing insults
I'll put next to an oldie but a goodie
we get our first major dilemma this
movie puts forth to us
barnacle butts and pooping and peanut
barrels I think you film credit for
setting the bar so low even an ATCO in
limbo under it deliver true the poor wee
ones orphanage so Santa send some of his
toys to an orphanage and I'm already
confused me motivation flips more than
HGTV's for line up in his off time
captain Santa non surprisingly enjoys
bowling but the crew finds out he's been
scamming them out of money by telling
his half-brother dinkle to rig the score
so they're tossed overboard meanwhile in
the North Pole we see one of the else
key clearly stolen out of his mind
yo ha ha ha blinking 4 Sobers he finds
the two frozen pirates washed up on the
hill the ocean has a really good arm and
all the elves gather around to do
various impressions of Rupert Everett's
career don't worry candle he's the great
white beard legs
what's the dingle Bob's are they what
are you gonna do with them form out by
asking Santa never thaw out monsters
oldest rule in the book we'll stand back
cuz I'm rewriting the book by Silver
Surfer is left nut I command you to thaw
reuse Neverland pipsqueaks at first the
Pirates want to attack but Santa gets an
idea
you what is this race it's the North
Pole welcome to you and your pet brat
white beard that's Rattus me
half-brother dingo to whom i'm bound
forever by blood well I find this true
for most Ingles the two of them
expressed their thanks to the elves and
why about them being pirates you two
wouldn't be pirates
[Music]
we're just Packers fans they're shown
the North Pole and I'll admit the main
workshop is actually a pretty unique
design as they explained that a lot of
their productivity is very magic ball
oriented I have me that mystic ball I
could steal every toy from here to
Timbuktu maybe I could even get skin not
made out of play-doh but what did the
elves do with the toys if they don't
deliver them to kids we play with them
and then store them in that mountain
over there
like I said clearly stoned off their
asses but the yells start marching
towards them and anger and Santa and
Dingle think they're on to them and try
throwing a ball out of them
oh so they were not they were just
showing off their angry March exercise
to the newcomers you know if he was an
NRA Santa you don't be bloody fruitcake
say it explains he was just playing his
favorite game elf boy pretty lame
connection considering the game already
had a very laid out story but your
five-year-olds already drunk on eggnog
from watching this so who's complaining
it's a surefire sign they like you white
beard the honorary throwing to
follow is also a sign of high flattery
they have their best chefs make Santa
strudel but there's another cream-filled
pastry both of them seem to be thinking
about rather you keep your hot screwed
on in your pants now now we know where
the PG came from Christ ELF bowling you
know a little something for the adults
because clearly a lot of grown-ups will
be watching a film with armpit farts in
it cool my kidding if this was a hit
that's totally possible hey buddy
what do you want
come on officials about mittens they
just fell off the truck why I haven't
seen the character so smoothly
introduced since I found out about
gitanos back having abilities he's got
my back the odds think Santa is a
prophet called white beard who will show
them their destiny you can give away the
toys we make to children every day of
the week yeah too much work how about
you just give him the toys on one
special day of the year Sam I leaning on
their religious upbringing
Krister still get a pass Santa agrees
and they give him a magic hat that
clearly didn't get his measurements
ahead of time it's fine as long as he
doesn't put on any weight he's
introduced to all the different elves
will first oh god I'm having rad city
street kids flashbacks find all your
Walter Jones's after he's introduced
everybody one of the elves gives them a
bit of advice oh thank god it's a
musical
[Music]
I bet Amazon sings this song every day
that's the Amazon anthem you know it's
funny there's a song about not being all
about the money in a movie version of
elf bawling no really we wanted to tell
this story for the art strudel dick
jokes must blossom are they screeching
at his voice or his Muppet ghost of
Christmas present wearing the Burger
King skin as a face mask not sure if
he's dropping off presents or multicolor
diarrhea but the elves are so happy at
his work that they make Santa and his
brother live forever by the way anyone
else noticed this kids film is kind of a
sick sense of humor which I'd be fine
with it most of the jokes weren't this
please go together like peanut butter
and peanut allergies Dingell on the
other hand kept trying to scheme people
for eons and eons and Santa kept having
to bail them out you know after
literally hundreds of years of this
would you revoke his immortality card
santa ends up marrying the chef who it
looks like is fed up with her brother
leeching off them did she say it's even
my strudel or death with noodle with
food having so many double entendres in
this I don't want to know what that
means you've been sleeping on my couch
for 600 years yeah got one week to find
yourself a nice bachelor might I suggest
not picking the one from North they get
there Cathy Bates's to do some risky
things dingo calls upon his to hedge
penguins to hatch a plan because this
time Santa ain't coming to town
might I also add up
[Applause]
[Music]
so Santa continues to do his ELF bowling
hey you gotta justify the title somehow
when one of the elves says their toy
count is off by 6 billion units I'm
challenging for Christmas
poop that makes about as much sense as
dueling to be the head of government
where's our ports for our caddy me
Awards so it's a strange he's been
living here hundreds of years yet he
never lost his pirate accent do kids
really want to think of Santa's the guy
who opens spongebob by the way if you
read this version that is a very
different meaning whoever wins gives
birth to baby Jesus where does he factor
in in all this well rabble whoever wins
this match of all matches becomes the
big cone of Christmas Hey who are we
televising to voice is in my hand mine
too
Santa's having a beef with his manager
and Dingle is having a problem with his
warmups
well at least we know the writers of
Vampires Suck are still getting work one
ball winner takes all it's like that
Super Bowl where one touchdown wins the
movies called elf bowling we can't
actually focus that much on elf bowling
in it the thing was replaced two of the
elves as part of their plan to cheat
[Music]
Dingle seems to be stretching his neck
in a terrifying nature I can only assume
came from Satan Prince of dark
oh yeah that's definitely Beelzebub and
too bad those pins can't talk and say
what happened wait those pins should
talk and say what happened let's cheat
again making it look like Santa lost
[Music]
please don't use the phrase beat me
dingo again but it's revealed he cheated
and santa ends up winning so I guess
that's it for the movie all wait there's
still 40 minutes left Joey
are there any questions I can go your
mom you know exactly what you said oh
yeah another song
[Music]
if I pretend this isn't needles in my
ballsack will you end faster just for
that another vas huh Christmas is in two
weeks and we're still short six billion
toys
oh yes swabs are killing me just cross
the hose off the list they're kind of
odd they probably won't mind the penguin
sabotage the machines and the head elf
gets blamed for it
first jealous come to the toys then you
short the machines now you blast me
girlfriends hey she came on to me I mean
I didn't do any that the head of quits
after being insulted but tinkle tell
Santa he ran out onto the ice and needs
to be saved
Santa finds out he's been fooled in the
machine at the workshop has a few
hiccups
remember always that my favorite movie
was home alone
yeah then things got awkward when they
posted the mission accomplished banner
Dingle makes it look like Santa betrayed
the man deals go on strike Dingle
suggests or rather sings about a new
spot they should head to okay the music
is clearly accompanying a different song
and how is it every movie I've reviewed
this December is a musical by people who
can't music they agreed to go to Fiji
and on the fly one of the passengers
here is that Dingle will probably become
a millionaire your new workshop at my
personal Resort in Fiji as you can tell
she clearly needs to marry into money
she gives him a spot to make the toys
and a song attached to it you know it
doesn't have a song in this elf bowling
the name of the goddamn movie and
apparently what the story is about but
everything is so forced and impractical
you're probably reenacting Edvard
Munch's Christmas card here
[Music]
his warm heart literally melts the ice
now let's be honest something else
probably broke through first the Santa
and his wife are reunited with a machete
and a lot of garbage bags Dingle rebuilt
the place as a sweat shop where he
hypnotizes the elves to make the toys
against their will yeah I got this cash
register just for that joke
I like wasting my spare time Dingle
steals the orb and zaps the elf with it
which calls for what else another
goddamn sword I'm immediately
uncomfortable with this one so I'm just
skipping it
Santa tries to stop them but tinkle uses
the orb to make stone bodyguards and
bury Santa in the sand what are you
doing here an impression of two dead
sand from Creepshow what do you think
I'm doing he gets him free in the chief
of the island uses his music to I guess
make a lady in the fire and nothing
surprises me anymore to get inside its
net the elves out of their hypnosis by
just spinning the wheel the other way I
have to admit that's a little funny
Dingle tricked us
he wrote that letter not Santa I trusted
that guy who literally had hundreds of
years of crimes under his belt
[Music]
this time our angry March is actually
because we're angry doing things for
reasons feels good
Santa chases his brother while his wife
and the owner of the resort well I'm
just gonna take a wild guess and say
they're not above a catfight she puts
her strudel in her mouth at this point I
don't care how you take that while the
head elf uses his son and magical powers
to get the orb to shock Dingle so now
what now I see what you did there he did
horribly and wasted the time of
everybody involved but I see what you
did there
so they do well falling again and once
again Dingle tries to cheat Crais does
every game means Randy to oversee it
well the elves are dead so I think that
counts as a strike actually they're
somehow untouched which once again
concludes that Dingle wins
you mean coconuts don't explode I don't
know what to believe anymore so once
again they hand victory to Santa Dingle
gets his comeuppance and they're allowed
to drop off the toys on Christmas
they even swing by the North Pole one
more time watch this Santa I'm gonna
kill any survivors the workshop is
restored kinda wondering why they didn't
just do that earlier ma fly odd
[Music]
he means Merry Christmas to all and to
all a good night that is if you haven't
turned off your DVD players already
we're assuming you have here's that
picture of Santa with a machine gun
again it was cooler than anything in
this it probably goes without saying but
this is not a very good fit
it's humor is either too childish for
adults too adult for children or too
stupid for both the animation isn't that
great though weirdly I can't say it's
the worst Christmas animation I've seen
and it just feels like it was written in
minutes to cash in on an already fading
zeitgeist it's not the worst Christmas
special but it's so disoriented and
lazily written that there's very little
to get out of it it's not the worst
waste of time but it's definitely not a
fun waste of time it's just a waste of
time now that's it for December as well
as the studio - I hope you guys have a
really good year and whatever changes
come your way I hope you make the best
of them I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to
Oh Oh did he forget to have a December
without Santa Christ oh and I had a good
story arc in everything I need a
wormhole in the sky and woke up in 1961
has Bobo the Astro chimp I had to make
sure this budding astronaut made the
space program or I'd die I'm the cooler
animal-testing I had to drink
Caterpillar juice and crap myself and
fumble through space testing and
everything but I guess that wasn't good
enough for you was it
oh-ho I guess wait till mrs. Christ
hears about this
Hey look boss I can do your mom
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out if you've been keeping up with
the news then you probably know
Indonesia has suffered this horrible
disaster or volcano has gone off and
that caused a tsunami that has killed
many many people and has destroyed so
many homes and so many lives so that's
why this charity this week we're doing
Save the Children this is one that we've
done before it's a very very good one
and they don't just specialize in the
saving children they specialize in
saving anyone in a disaster just like
this they go into areas that most people
are running away from and this one
specifically is for this tragedy is for
the Indonesia tsunami and volcano
eruptions so they do really amazing work
and you can you can go their YouTube
channel and check them out you can go
their site but mainly just just donate
we're gonna have a link that goes
directly to this cause for Save the
Children because they do have one for
this specifically so please definitely
go click on the link that this is a
terrible thing that's happened and
around this time of year around this
holiday we really want to show that
there's people that care for them and
we're willing to help so definitely
click on the link and show your support
you